[Music]
democrats led by president biden
say now is the time to build back better
the american jobs plan will modernize
20 000 miles of highways roads and main
streets
that are in difficult difficult shape
right now
but leaders don't just want to build and
update roads
in some cases they want highways torn
down
democrats would like to provide funding
to tear down highways that had a
damaging effect on urban minority
communities
federal funds created the damage done
here and
federal funds should be used to help
remedy it
activists in cities like tampa austin
texas new orleans detroit
and tulsa oklahoma are calling for the
removal of highways
that they say segregate communities and
harm minorities
leaders say there are many more examples
like this road in west baltimore
this is the franklin mulberry expressway
baltimore locals call it the highway to
nowhere
and some policymakers want to tear it
down
the road cuts through 1.4 miles of the
city providing a speedy route for cars
traveling east to west like other parts
of the country's interstate system
the road was built to provide fast
access for traffic from ports and
downtown offices
to the suburbs but locals like baltimore
city councilman john bullock
say it's a scar running through the
city's west side
the reality is that you did have intact
businesses churches
uh families uh community networks that
were literally torn asunder with this
highway going through and yes they're
examples of cities across the country
and baltimore
is no different that during urban
renewal you saw the disproportionate
effects
in neighborhoods that had
african-american populations
planning for this road dates back to the
1950s when president eisenhower called
for cities to build better connections
to the interstate system his goal was to
give the military
traders and commuters quick routes
through the nation
in baltimore the first round of
demolition displaced hundreds of
families
that sparked a wave of opposition from
locals like then city councilwoman
barbara mikulski
who would go on to represent maryland in
congress as a democrat
the government under eminent domain took
their housing cleared that land without
any relocation benefits
without a fair market value and so on
senator chris van hollen is mikulski's
successor
what you see here is a part of the
highway that was
built decades ago but was never
completed
because senator mikulski and other
activists
rallied to stop it and they were
successful at stopping the highway but
not before
this one and a half mile segment had
been built
displacing over 900 people from their
home splitting
an african american community that had
been stable
and vibrant and so here you see this
scar
since then researchers have found that
highways create challenging conditions
within cities
data collected in baltimore suggests
that air quality is poorest in the
sections of the city that are near
interstate connections
the environmental protection agency says
that poor air quality
can worsen health conditions like asthma
the interstate also contributed to
out-migration not only in baltimore
but in cities across the country like
detroit
economists say that the highway building
in majority black detroit
contributed to the city's economic
decline
maintenance costs for these roads
continue to weigh on the city
which filed for bankruptcy in 2013
this form of structural inequity is what
leaders in washington
say they are trying to address too often
investments have failed to meet the
needs of marginalized communities left
behind
developers today say that tearing down
parts of the interstate system could
correct a wave of past failures
one 2018 review of west baltimore calls
for the demolition of two bridges at the
eastern stub of the highway
opening more land for development
the plan says the new space could be
used for athletic fields
parks and a new retail center the panel
also called for the rehabilitation of
vacant lots
and nearby row homes and wider sidewalks
for pedestrians
if congress passes an infrastructure
bill the federal funding could help turn
some of these ideas
into reality west baltimore community
organizer ishia parker
says she would welcome changes in her
part of the city but she wants to make
sure the community has a seat at the
table
we definitely don't want our federal
partners putting up large condos
that people aren't able well that
current residents aren't able to occupy
and then we also want to make sure that
economic development is done so produce
stores or
other type of small businesses for
people who are already in a neighborhood
that can utilize other residents said
that they would like for the government
to focus on rehabilitating homes in the
area
before focusing on the roads
the national movement to tear down
highways is picking up steam
as leaders in congress from both sides
of the aisle signal that they're open to
the idea
the movement got a boost from president
biden when he called for 20 billion
dollars
to redress inequities created by past
investments in transportation
that's just one part of the bigger
american jobs plan which the white house
says
would cost 1.7 trillion dollars
senate republicans now say that they are
open to a nearly one trillion dollar
infrastructure plan
in short both parties want to invest
more in infrastructure
but they're far apart on the details of
how it should be done
republican senators say they're open to
using federal funds to remove highways
but they want to leave the decision to
state lawmakers
there are multiple examples of poor
planning decisions that have led to
adverse consequences for specific
communities none of us deny that
and i think we all agree they should be
rectified
i believe it should be done at the local
and state level where decision makers
are closest to the people and able to
make a balanced
decision the call to fund highway
removal
breaks from years of american
transportation philosophy
if a bill materializes highway teardowns
could unfold
in cities across the country
you